[Music]
right after school I just like chatting
like once of a gym so I can climb it
it's a dangerous sport but I only think
that I'm afraid of is not being able to
get to this office with climbing I don't
think that it really matters with how
big you are if you're smaller you can
hold on longer and your hands might be
smaller so I can fit more fingers on
hold I started climbing in Central Park
when I was six years old now I don't
think I could like live without it
when we're close to the top of the climb
you're trying to do confirms usually
feel like they're going to explode and
they're going to like first open and you
feel like you have to let go but it's
climbing you just can't let go I think
that climbing is it's obviously a sport
it's also like a dance you sort of have
to be able to like flow up the wall and
come up with your own techniques to get
to the copper
I think people shocked if I do something
that they can't do is something because
I'm still really young and I'm a girl so
like doing something that even if a guy
can't do is pretty special
other few would laugh at me in fact all
my friends say we worry about you
jealous you know
and they even coming up this weekend
somebody said oh now be careful I think
that's ridiculous what a better way to
die having fun I am a world record
holder for being the oldest woman
skydiver
in the world I think is there's only one
way it's down so either five got slight
absent-mindedness I'll be all right
I don't worry that my carpets is rather
threadbare and old as long as I'm
skydiving but I do get scared and I used
to be so scared that I would drive the
car up to the the drop zone and think I
could go back I don't have to stay here
but I knew if I went away I'd never come
back again
so the the the ecstasy was more than the
fear the first time I jumped up an arrow
played I thought I was really dying and
as I fell I thought what a mistake this
is death I just remember it now and then
the next second I thought ah I'm flying
[Music]
skydiving uses the most intense
wonderful feeling I mean people come
down from the sand and jump and they all
say it's better than sex I will take
that the way you like it but it is
[Music]
I think sometimes we get pulled out by
fear we get pulled down by necessity of
work and it's a mistake but having done
skydive I learned courage I learned to
go and that has been the biggest turning
point in my life and I think the courage
has helped me to run a charity which
from scratch is very difficult I they
say most charities fail after three
years and I knew that I had a program
that affected for the good they
profoundly disabled people made them
really much happier and that thrills me
I believe we all have a purpose in life
and I believe that extras is my purpose
I don't have much time to think about
the past I'm so busy in the present and
just going into the future that the past
recedes and I am enjoying so much these
days
remembering the past remembering even
the difficult times but seeing how they
all fell into a pattern which now I'm
glad of you are a bird for 50 seconds
and imagine you can go 240 miles an hour
you can do a barrel roll you can flick
you can move here you can move there you
can join up with people it is
unbelievably wonderful I won't stop till
I know it's not safe but for now I'm
safe and I can do it and I will do it
for as long as I can I think it's fun
making passers I mean I don't like to do
it from 9 a.m. to 10 o'clock at night
but that's what comes with having a
business you need to do the orders you
don't just get money for doing nothing
[Music]
welcome to keep my house with the Modi
is such a good my name is Mira Modi and
I love pass for making as you know one
big happy family
I make passwords that are very secure
and I have a website when I sell them
for fuel our Beach and I send them by
postal mail
I roll dice to make strings of numbers
use the string of numbers to get
corresponding words in the dice or
dictionary
I roll dice five times for each word oh
you do that six times for one password
so all that s 30 times and it produces
random words that have a lot of entropy
which means it's not easy for the
computer to have kind of like turn into
a thing I would do like if my mom's
friend you're like come over like hey
can you make me a couple passwords and I
do it then I was like well let's make it
into a website and here I mean the
website is up and I'm really excited
about that
some people like safe being popular in
schools like the best thing ever I think
like this is so much better people
actually like learn from this and that's
good Anish unique I probably have if I
don't have it I can get a few in 24
hours fear up and you have a video shoot
me the shoes coming out in two weeks I
just have to make a call and I'll get it
for you
[Music]
every day millions of people tune to DJ
Khaled snapchat the key to more
successful to have a lot of pillows one
of my favorite DJ kala pearance is is
this kid Ben how's business in a new
year oh I see you he's 16 years old and
he's at the helm of a burgeoning sneaker
empire when he says has done nearly a
million dollars in business and boasts
clients like DJ Khaled and Chris Brown
studio meet this sneaker Don so my name
is Benjamin capitalistic people call me
Benjamin cakes but most you guys know me
as a sneaker don school ends at 3
o'clock I get home outlook for you
dinner do some homework then go straight
to the office space and like any good
Don family's important
oh there's Lois brother I'm his manager
so if you need anything call me okay not
that family I'm the mother of the
sneaker Don to me he's my little boy but
I also see a business and he had a goal
he's self driven he's motivated he's a
hard worker the great Don's they say
come from humble beginnings the first
person he's actually got me a sneak game
I was in fifth grade the galaxy pack
came out and I got the LeBrons I love
sneakers after that probably around
sixth grade when my parents didn't want
to fund my sneaker hobby anymore I'd
figure out a way how to get the money
for it and then I realized if I buy five
or ten pairs by paying people to stand
in line for me I could sell it to a
larger clientele and make more money
plus get my shoe for free then it just
finally broke through and the money you
started coming in at first it amazed me
how sneakers can go for like so much
money for like one shoe people charging
a thousand I thought Jose can choke or
something I was in dollars but hey
that's why he's the sneaker Don
so what comes next really excited to
open up a physical store the first
locations I mean Miami then I'm trying
to LA New York and Chicago all my
friends when they dropped out of sneak
game they like it's dead it's over
there's no more like you're not getting
on there think you're wasting your time
you're gonna lose money not about what
was true play themselves indeed they did
sneak her down indeed they did people
ask me that question all the time what
it feels like to get hit it's like a
little explosion in your body if they
hit you at the right spot but I'm not
really trying to hurt them actually
except when when I'm hitting the body I
really like hearing people who like
drugs there are very few female boxers
that are still in the game that have the
longevity in the sport that I've had in
20 years of boxing I've never been
knocked out much less knocked down and I
think the reason for that it's not just
because I'm strong it's because I don't
take punches I'm never there to get
punched
it's weird it's very hard for me to
associate being world champion with my
name I mean I have an office that as my
belt and all these photos of all the
different titles that I've won but I
just don't feel like it applies to me
I was a dancer so only when I was
injured and knew that I couldn't dance
anymore that I took up something else
just for exercise so went into
kickboxing and eventually into boxing
because I started out as a dancer one of
the biggest elements that I bring into
my boxing is movement when I first came
into boxing there are very few women and
the mentality of the guys that were here
were that you shouldn't box you're too
pretty to box you know go back to dance
or something else this is a sport like
any other sport I can do it any female
can do it the best recognition I had was
when someone said she fights like
Pernell Whitaker or Muhammad Ali then
say I fought like a female I'm 48 and
for my next fights I'm going to try to
be the oldest female title holder and
that would be in the Guinness world
record so there's different things that
I need to win there's different things
that I need to do and world champion is
just one of it
[Music]